[Musique]
en août 1942 l'armée nazie en raison des
lourdes pertes sur le front de l'est
annonce que plus de 130 mille jeunes
hommes des territoires annexés d'alsace
et de lorraine et 10000 luxembourgeois
sont appelés sous la bannière de la
wehrmacht
la plupart d'entre eux n'avaient pas
envie de servir leur âge ils
s'appelaient entre eux
les malgré nous et une fois en
territoire ennemi se sont rendus dans
l'espoir de rejoindre l'armée du général
de gaulle mais beaucoup d'entre eux ont
échoué à la station radar ou camps de
prisonniers numéro 188 près de tambov en
actuelle russie comme en témoignent les
documents conservés dans les archives
d'état de la région de tambov et les
souvenirs d'anciens prisonniers de
guerre notre invité est philippe wilmut
docteur en histoire président de
l'association pour la conservation de la
mémoire de la moselle en 1939 1945 et
responsables du musée de la moselle en
1939 1940 bonjour monsieur wilmut
pouvez-vous commencé par nous dire qui
sont les malgré nous dans l'est malgré
tout ça concerne des populations qui
sont à l'est de la france
un sacre au cern trois départements
c'est-à-dire l'alsace de département et
la moselle ce sont des gens qui des
hommes une hausse initiale
les faits qui ont été incorporés de
force de l'armée allemande en le revend
ce qu'un malaise existe déjà l'une des
mais en fait en 1920 ça concernait des
citoyens allemands puisque nous on était
un excellent de droit alors qu'en 1942
on était annexé de fait et donc on a
grandi que en a incorporé des français
dans une halle ou dans une armée ennemie
qui a été reconnu comme un crime de
guerre
pourquoi s'appelle-t-il ainsi le monde
des loups a été effectivement créée en
1904 parce que après la première guerre
mondiale se sont développées les
associations pour ses combattants pour
obtenir des droits des réparations
graciant et il se trouve que c'est ces
lois les scènes mosellan noués par
bénéficier puisqu'il avait porté
l'uniforme allemand et il ya donc les
coûts d'une réunion d'anciens
combattants un ancien combattant qu'est
et porter l'uniforme allemand l'a fait
remarqué lors ils ont fait aux soldats
français quitter la salle qui avait
compris le problème et il a dit ben non
on est effectivement dans l'armée
allemand mais certains d'autres mots en
porter l'uniforme leur coeur défendant
ses valises aurélie se sont sentis
obligés qu'ils avaient leurs sentiments
français mais les circonstances en fait
qu'ils ont dû porter l'uniforme allemand
et donc c'est même un encas soldats
français et d'un soldat bleu horizon qui
a inventé cet acronyme malgré nos débuts
donc c'est cette association qui a
existé pendant tout l'entré deux guerres
qui était d'ailleurs attaché en outre
l'association française des rations
selon la fédération des mutuelles de la
grande guerre et donc elle a existé
jusqu'en 1940 par les allemands en excès
zain a été évidemment interdite et même
les membres de cette association ont été
expulsés en menaçant 40 parce qu'une
soupe connaissez pas le mans et ans donc
il ya eu une deuxième génération de
malgré-nous en 1940 2009 n'étaient pas
des signalements et en 45
la der à cesser les quais on était dans
l'armée allemande
derrière qui est l'association déjà les
malgré-nous modifie les statuts et en a
gardé en tous les cas ces termes là
surtout lausanne les
assia leur association sachant que les
incorporés de force et un côté dans
luxembourg on les appelle les eaux
rouler les envolées de france en terme
de chiffres qu'est ce que cela
représente combien de français se sont
retrouvés dans ce camp de la région de
tambov combien d'entre eux ont survécu
et combien sont morts
donc pour les alsaciens mosellans il ya
eu à peu près cent trente mille
incorporés de force dans l'armée
allemande
la plupart des malgré-nous en combattre
à l'est ça fait moi aussi parce que les
combats à partir de 1942 et était là
haut et que et donc il ya sur ses 130 me
alsaciens mosellans en estime maintenant
à peu près à 15000 ceux qui se sont
retrouvés dendre corps alors ils sont
pas retrouvés effectivement quasiment du
jour au lendemain ça s'est fait
progressivement par exemple narrant les
ce qui s'est passé c'est que le
gouvernement qui était français qui
étaient à londres à un moment dit aux
autorités russes que parmi les
prisonniers allemands se trouvaient des
français incorporés de force
et quel esprit bien de dans les
rassembler et peut être utilisé un
statut spécial et c'est ce qui s'est
passé à partir de femmes 243 donc là en
1 créée au sein d'un conte qui existait
déjà quand 188 donc à tambov un quartier
des français donc la partie de descendre
à 143 arrive des alsaciens mosellans ans
et que au moment d'une premier transfert
en algérie donc le 7 juin 1944
il était à peu près mille huit cent dans
dans le camp visionnant les chalands ont
libéré les cinq sens les 300 qui a été
dit gré c'était souvent des malades qui
était intransportable et finalement
c'est après juillet 1944 que ça arrive
et la plupart des alsaciens mosellans
certains en fait deux hivers la plupart
un hiver et il y en a même certains qui
n'ont pas effectivement pas subi divers
le terrible lire jusqu'ici
il faisait très froid et pas ce pays
sont arrivés que tardivement parce que
le camp de tambov a servi aussi à
transfert des alsaciens mosellans après
la capitulation
dans quelles conditions les dessins des
anciens prisonniers de tambov ont-ils
été réalisés voilà en fait la une il
existe très peu d'image sur d'image
c'est à dire de photoquai les cas du
comptable con comme et nous c'est
surtout une photo qui correspondent au
transfert du 7 juin 1944 qui est
effectivement filmées par les autorités
russes
et on a un extrait de ses films de
nombreuses photos et qu'il pourrait
cependant pas tout à fait à la réalité
de la ville atteint voir parce que
c'était quand même ce transfert à la
prendre et bien occupé des crises donné
à la salle libéré gad d'y aller
combattre en afrique du nord ce qui
devrait en mai donc on n'avait pas
d'image est évidemment quand l'élève et
des alsaciens mosellans d'autres
populations parce que l'existence y est
parce qu il existe aussi des dessins
sont rentrés certains estiment aux élans
voulu laisser de traces mais tant qu ils
ont laissé parmi les a d'ailleurs il ya
aussi des artistes avait déjà dessiné et
ont donc en a commencé à dessiner
ils ont commencé à dessiner leur vécu
leur vie quotidienne et on n'a rien dit
et ça qu'ils se ressemblent parce que
copier jours
c'est comme utiliser les autres mais ça
s'est fait assez vite et surtout en 1967
il ya eu une première grande exposition
sur le camp de tambov qui a été lu rhône
alsace et là il ya nancy alors c'était
pas un ancien prof c'est un artiste
alsacien mais qui avait été dans les
chorus par atteindre of men qui a été
dans les chorus et eux en façade avec
les souvenirs des en septembre fils a
fait tomber une bande dessinée
on a fait une trentaine de grands grands
desseins qui figure dans le pratiquant
tous les livres sur un album et on a
effectivement raconter cette vie attaque
gauche à travers les dessins parce qu'il
n'existait rien alors maintenant on
commence à trouver quelques photos dans
les archives à moscou dans les dossiers
deviennent calme idée mais c'est assez
rare à quoi ressemblait la vie
quotidienne des prisonniers construction
mémoire qu'on appelle des histoires on
appelle ça une construction même victime
est ce à dire que effectivement quand un
bon la première c'est ça qui s'est créé
et fait un push est à 2965 bientôt après
la guerre parce que en 1960 on a
commencé à indemniser les victimes du
nazisme par tournoi l'allemagne a des
misères aux corps des victimes et les
ont fait un mort en voulu se faire
reconnaître comme didier nazisme et
surtout roux dit voilà on a atteint une
telle maladie parce que on a été interné
à talbot ya certainement en un certain
nombre aussi le trait mais dont tous les
mois témoignage en fait ce qui est vrai
c'est que rihanna qui ont été faits
prisonniers et donc lino 6 sont rendus
aux russes moi je suis français je peins
combat très exactement
mais pour que ma famille ne sera pas
inquiétée
je vais sur le franc est la première
occasion je me rends au russe dames en
attendant on sait très bien que
la population qui goûtaient autour du
camp elles souffraient de la faim donc
c'était assez dur quand ils sont rentrés
dans le camp dix étaient souvent il y
avait un interrogatoire
il y avait une visite médicale qui a
laissé pas forcément débours sonia parce
que c'est fait par des femmes met donc
les pierrots il faut quand même leur
classe et ça dans son contexte
géographique d'un beau flash et la 450
km au sud est de moscou dont clichés où
il fait froid c'est d hiver qui sont
plus rigoureux que le génie on est dans
l'est de la france qui sont le centre
est lent et donc c'est qu'on y des
conditions naturelles la captivité était
très difficile lorsqu'on était en et en
russie pour lisière survivre vous pouvez
l'intérieur pas avoir trop d'activités
parce que tous les dg s'est par exemple
qu'aucune n'est mort les mots ne pouvait
pas être enterré pendant l'hiver et il
était stocké dans une villa dans
l'accent 22 donc jusqu'à se lier en plus
les enterrer creuser la terre pour
pouvoir faire des 10 cultures et donc
nous on a par exemple une collection
d'objets qui a été ramené de thann nov
on sent bien que la préoccupation des
internet c'est la survie c'est à dire
que les objets c'est une canne elle
c'est une cuillère en bois
c'est un morceau perrin qui a été
transformé en en couteaux s'étaient
aussi les gens qui eux étaient accros au
tabac est d'ailleurs la meilleure
institution est donc iront même d'aller
dans les bras qui a un destin qui est
assez symbolique où on voit des gens qui
dans une base de teint c'est dire que
ans en faisait des tranches de pain et
pour qu'il y ait pas de rivalité entre
les interner pour king d'égalité pour
dans les rations en en faisait le cas
pour tout le monde et la même chose
les habitants de la station radar
hamnett hill à manger aux soldats
français qui étaient sur le camp je
pense que dans toute l'année dont on
sait que c'est très compliqué il ya
toujours des formes de solidarité qui se
crée entre les hommes quoique
alors évidemment je les dis précédemment
les la population qui étaient autour du
port avait très peu à manger
malgré tout il est fort probable
il a bon ça ne sont que des témoins des
témoignages pour trouver comment
impulser mais quand on écoute les gérer
asa cerveau et l'ont pu aller en au
chili dans les années 90 où
effectivement d'anciens a compté qui n'a
pas mangé des choux des pages mais on
s'aperçoit pas s'il a existé l'avait
choisie si on en moselle il y avait des
populations elle est notamment des
prisonniers de guerre qui était
maltraitée quand même dans les aliments
sains et qui ont gelé car la nourriture
était important que c'était aussi une
forme de pression pour faire travailler
les gens dans une interview jean tu es
président de la fédération des anciens
de tambov a dit que des prisonniers
avait épousé des femmes soviétique et
était resté en urss
êtes vous au courant de l'existence de
tels cas alors moi je ne connais pas
j'ai un peu des douze sous les couleurs
de l'école et les malgré-nous qui était
quand même pour fermer alors ça pue 4
exister si les gars
ils sortaient du camp salaire pendant
les cours vous pouvez effectivement
avoir une relation bien si c'est pas des
ducs ont laissé avant et c'était de se
dire par contre il ya eu certainement
d'autres français qui se sont retrouvés
le reste puisque au fur et à mesure de
l'avancée des troupes soviétiques des
camps notamment de prisonnier de guerre
en d'aidé militaire il y avait quand
même mis deux années de guerre français
qui dans la halle mail mais l'allemagne
fallait juste pour pru cela jusqu'au
pologne
les bielles aussi tout c'est une
population française si deal qui avait
été réquisitionné au cadre du service du
travail obligatoire qui se retrouve en
allemagne et comptent les vitraux peu
soviétique est mort en avance et
l'allemagne ils ont libéré des camps ces
populations étaient mis à l'arrière et
l'a peut-être et qu'effectivement il ya
eu des relations qui ont été établis
entre lessive je sais que d'ici de la
presse locale quelque temps on a évoqué
le retour au tout les cas d'un ami noir
alors qu'il était pas mal de noix mais
quitter les prisonniers de guerre et qui
a laissé sa vie en russie et qui bon
après la fin de sa vie il a vu revenir
au temps c'est un appel
donc ça fait la venue de la précision ce
sont des cas des cas très très très rare
c'était très difficile d'aborder un
genre de relation pourquoi les
malgré-nous sont ils parfois considérés
comme des oubliés de l'histoire
heureux comme je voulais dire seulement
le problème et malgré nos départements
en france des territoires qui sont
situées à l'est de la france en fait à
la frontière de france et d'allemagne et
qui s'était ricouart été souvent l'enjeu
de guerres précédentes puisque en 10 70
des français ont perdu ici on a été 48
ans allemands donc aujourd'hui ma
famille tous mes grands parents sont nés
allemands qui sont nés avant avant 1914
ils deviennent français qu'après 14 et
d'élus les allemands eux ont considéré
que ces sept autres de gars c'était une
parenthèse 10 ans et pour certains
français finalement de bain en été on
était des téléphones on aidé des
allemands à dire en corse région en
somme des ça existe encore et
donc on n'a pas eu la même histoire que
le reste de la france en a une histoire
vraiment comment différentes
on n'est même pas en territoire occupé
en nouveaux territoires annexés dire
qu'on est vraiment du jour au lendemain
parce que par la force puisque là c'est
une une annexion d'hommes de fait en
devient allemand et en plus on devient
allemand sous un régime nazi ce qui a
compliqué la donne
jeudi roman pendant la première annexion
les gens sauront lui puisque facilité à
s'adapter déjà les villes telle tant est
que les allemands après la première
année sans nom on fait une élection qui
a été qui n'a pas été brutal alors que
l'art 940 tourin changer très vite
fédérer germinal et était revenu de deux
mois alors que les pans de la première
élection ils ont mis quarante ans
et puis il ya une oasis c'est à dire que
ça c'est à dire que de logis
totalitaires dans toute cette histoire
là les bas partagé par les français et
pas partie de l'histoire nationale en
est une histoire régionale
effectivement il ya toute une
littérature existe sur cette histoire là
mais elle a du mal à sortir de ces trois
départements
même quand il ya des documentaires ils
sont pas sots des chaînes régionales
nationales le 9 août 1998
un monument à la mémoire des malgré nous
a été inauguré à tambov certains anciens
combattants et où leurs proches sont
venus à l'inauguration
pourquoi selon vous est il nécessaire de
restaurer et de protéger la mémoire de
sept pages difficiles de l'histoire de
la france mais aussi de la russie
la deuxième guerre mondiale elle est
témoin et vous un événement majeur dans
ce 20ème siècle et effectivement il ya
eu volonté de préserver cette mémoire la
sémer mois différentes je dis rien comme
il était dit et n'a cessé même plus deux
associations de danse est à bord qui ont
été créées à partir des années mais à 65
donc en alsace moselle et en dehors de
la réparation il ya eu aussi volonté de
laisser trace donc les désagréments de
livres et même avant 1998 il ya eu dès
que l'on aura pu présenter kung
actuellement en urss a découlé facile
allez en urss
il ya certains anciens de tambov qui ont
dû faire un pèlerinage lieu de
l'internement actuel qui était un des
premiers à avoir été à table au choix
dès 1980 donc ils ont visité une petite
délégation
effectivement après le plan politique
aussi manifesté son intérêt pour ces
séances est un porche en 1998
une inauguration avec ministre au
désastre combattants turcs lerma serait
donc sur la forêt de ragga qui a
inauguré une stèle et il ya eu d'autres
séquelles initialement qui existe des
mof en mémoire des malgré nous car elle
même qui s'appelle pas des malgré nous
qui devait s'appeler comme ça
initialement et je sais que les anciens
combattants du secteur de tanner pas
voulu qui s'appelle comme ça parce que
ça faisait référence à des cds allemand
et donc c'est devenu le monument de la
l'amitié franco allemand est alors
pourquoi ça lui de garder cette mémoire
je protège bon en j'ai en tout cas les
anciens pâtissant devenue en plus vieux
qu'ils ont pu se pencher sur leur
histoire ils avaient une volonté mais
ces tracés qui donc
ivaylo a été comme un pèlerinage pascal
aura une volée leur jeunesse donc déjà
ça a été d'abord eux qui ont été sur
leur train les traces de leur histoire
après ils ont emmené leurs enfants
et après il ya les politiques
effectivement qui rouge
si c'est des liens d'amitié je pense
entre deux pays qui en sont d il ya
qu'ils soient ces fonds étaient souvent
alliés et n'est donc voilà il y a
vraiment une volonté de conserver cette
cette mémoire sauf que ça se délite avec
le temps c'est quand même le fait d
anciens et pour conclure que faut-il
faire pour que la mémoire des malgré
nous soit entretenu c'est difficile
parce que c'est un jeu dire les
associations dans les associations de
malgré nous elles sont très disparaît à
suivre la main en moselle n'existe plus
depuis 2014
donc il ya en alsace il existe encore
une association métier qui va forcément
disparaître des anciens quoi il ya par
exemple un pagne n'existe pas et
d'associations des enfants de malgré
nous il n'y a pas eu volonté des enfants
va conserver
la mémoire de leur demeure et en france
évidemment c'est pas volonté politique
de de conserver cette mémoire la des
territoires annexés
c'est un particularisme local en france
on n'aime pas trop les particularismes
on essaie de faire une histoire
nationale et donc en parle en effet
d'éviter de parler de ces de ces
problèmes dans locaux il ya eu un
discours important pour les malgré-nous
ses discours du président sarkozy
donc il ya quelques années à colmar en
alsace qui a reconnu donc les malgré
nous et être victime de la guerre est
donc il ya eu comme une autorité
nationale qui a qui a fait rentrer les
malgré nous dans une catégorie de
victimes de la guerre dans un territoire
français mais c'est une exception quand
je dis re gagné jeudi en france viennent
toujours une forme d'incompréhension et
en fait c'est les surtout les alsaciens
qui se battent pour l'anc en respecte
comprennent une histoire d année c est d
mariani quand ces connexions et eux et
on va avoir du mal être je pense que
effectivement je vais que en est des
initiatives locales comme mémorial chaud
mais que nous et nous admirons peine en
base d'un son d'une structure mais les
voilà quelque chose de professionnel
peut-être mais ça c'est pas le moment
ressort c'est des décisions politiques
et là je ne suis pas sûr que en franche
en devenir
la volonté de vouloir forcément conservé
cette histoire majeur
merci de nous avoir suivis merci à notre
invité est un très bientôt sur arte
france
[Musique]